a lot of people know you guys did some
additional photography on Dark Phoenix I
think a lot of people want to know what
you did and so can you reveal or talk
about what actually you guys did what
you wanted to punch up in the movie and
also I just want to say on camera every
movie has additional photography this is
not some radical thing that just this
movie is doing right every movie does
this every big movie I mean I think
there's some movies that don't do it but
I think any movie that has scale and
frankly the wherewithal financially to
do it the support of the studio to do it
does it and one thing that one of the
many things that that Marvel Studios
does so brilliantly as they build into
their budgets a reshoot period because I
think it's the same way the writing a
screenplay is an iterative process where
you're writing Draft after draft it
makes sense the way the Marvel does of
the way that Pixar does it that actually
making the movies an iterative process
as well so you're learning as you're
making the film you're learning is
you're editing the film what it needs so
what we did just when we went up to
shoot and Montreal this mostly we focus
from the third out both emotionally and
in terms the physical scale in the
action of the third act we adjust it and
then there were certain things in the
first two acts the movie very very few
things but to set up those changes in
the third act we had to adjust some
things in the first two acts so that
that all was fluid and felt and it was
yea consistent designed was a I guess my
question is in what we wanted to know
like how long were you up there and how
long we sheets it was like a week or two
to three it was two and half weeks the
first unit photography and so here's a
big question which I also I want to know
this you release the trailer and then
like a day later announce a date change
how did that not get figured out the day
before before the trailer is going to
drop well it probably should have some
of the trailers that come in soon on
them and some of them said February 14th
who was a date February 14th that we
initially like
but when we realized that we weren't
going to have the visual effects ready
to release it globally the way we wanted
to and the gambit date as you mentioned
earlier opened up because it wasn't
going to be ready for that June 7th date
we looked at that date versus the
February 14th day the studio did and we
did we felt like that June date was a
bigger opportunity for us globally more
screenings more IMAX screens about a
chance to play in China where these
movies have a massive following will be
found when we released the trailer was
that 44 or 45 million views of the
trailer were in China alone for hours
and then and that was a notable
benchmark for Fox yeah and also as much
as we tend to think that only in terms
of Dark Phoenix for Fox
they had other issues that were looking
at and wanting to figure out the best
circumstances for so you know wasn't
just our Phil but also I think they
moved everything so they have Deadpool
moved Aleta Aleta moved with us when we
moved on gambit gambit moves the
following year these sort of Domino
effects happen on movies but specific
for us it was you know it is an
opportunity to be a bigger movie day and
a globally yeah I'm gonna say because
with that push so you are gonna try
that's probably if a day and date around
the world you know then also helps with
piracy yes that well that that is true
and in certain territories that's the
truest you know that's the reason for
day to date and it's it's it's
definitely something that while it
wasn't ideal that team the day after
that we but the teaser it was something
that as we all looked at it particularly
in light of the China information but
the the global release all being allowed
to live much more coherently was was the
big big attractive and also and in terms
of the the trailer release it certainly
probably shouldn't have said 214 on it
but the audience and certainly I know
this because I live online as much as
anybody people wanted to see something
from the movie
time to show something from the movie so
I would have still released a tease that
when we released it I just wouldn't
coming soon on the end of it I will put
you in seventh though we hadn't really
had made that decision